the Joe Rogan experience explained the
record you broke you ran 24 oh in less
well it was a hundred miles and it's a
24-hour time pair but you did it in 11
hours and 41 minutes yeah so um it was
yeah let me explain a little Booker so
it was a the event itself was called six
days in the dome and really what it was
was you could do anything from a 24-hour
event to a 48 or event to a six-day
event and just see how far you could run
within that time for days yeah I know
there's some crazy people out there so
just wait till David Goggin spines that
event but yeah so I've been it's
interesting because there's not a lot of
time events that are necessarily
structured 400 mile or for like 12 hours
so a lot of times you find yourself
jumping into some of these other events
that are longer in duration and just
kind of using them as a way to try to
run a fast hundred mile er or a fast 12
hour so the race director for for that
particular event had reached out to me
because he he's known me for a while and
knew that I was targeting fast hundred
mile times and just said hey I've got
this cool event set up at the Olympic
training facility in Milwaukee Wisconsin
at the Pettit Center and I think it's
gonna be pretty conducive for fast for
fast times and and asked I wanted to do
it so I actually didn't have an ideal
timeline to that I would have normally
wanted to work with in terms of getting
ready for it but the training went
really well and I went there targeting
the hundred mile world record which was
11 hours 28 minutes and three seconds
prior to that and ended up running 11
hours 19 minutes and 13 seconds for 100
miles and then since we have like this
100 mile distance and also this 12 hour
timed event kind of structure you can
find yourself if you're under 12 hours
kind of double dipping and getting to
events for the price of one I guess you
could say so I kept running after I hit
100 miles and ended up going 100 4.88
miles total in the 12 hour time frame so
that was another record yeah those two
world records 100 miles in 12 hours
dude 6 minutes and 48 seconds for a pace
for a hundred miles is [ __ ] bonkers
that is so fast that's so crazy that's
such a fast pace man
yeah you know it's funny like when you
look at it because I think sometimes
people look at like a hundred miles in
11 hours and 19 minutes and there's not
a lot of context and they're - they're
kind of familiar with ultramarathon
running mm-hmm but when you start to
break it down into like the
subcategories where it's like well
that's like for like sub three-hour
marathons in a row or I can't remember
how many or what the 5k time is there's
a it's like 31 five K's at some
sometimes four sub three-hour marathons
in a row yeah wow that's so crazy
that's so fast and are you still eating
mostly meat uh so you know this gets
brought up quite a bit I think because I
mean I eat a ton of animal products for
sure but you know I wouldn't classify
myself as a quote unquote carnivore or
quite in this is the carnivore diet
people want to claim you we discussed
this kind of the last time you were here
where you take in a lot of glucose and
you you ramp up your carbohydrates
considerably before a race like what is
what is your what is a daily diet let's
say in training you're preparing for
something like this what's a daily diet
for you like yeah yeah so yeah let's
jump into that I think there is some
nuance within that even because when you
think of my lifestyle the way I like
describe it is if you took a calendar
year and you grabbed a single day out of
there and you grabbed a day where I was
yet like a peak training day versus a
recovery day those are like so
drastically different in terms of my
energy and my my energy demands so like
things tend to fluctuate quite a bit and
change quite a bit and I think that's
oftentimes what confuses people because
they want to they look at what I'm doing
say on race day they look at what I'm
doing on one of my big workout days or
my rest day and think that's what I'm
doing across the board so you and you
get the folks saying oh well zach
follows a carnivore diet they're
probably looking at like a post-race
recovery day where then I might be
eating almost all just animal products a
lot of eggs a lot of salmon you know red
meats that sort of stuff but if you pick
a day out where I'm doing like a big
training day doing like a 30-mile run or
something like that
that's where I'm going to kind of bring
back some of the carbohydrates to try to
supplement that activity and the best
way to maybe describe it is uh you know
there's like this this that kind of
Train low race high or this carb
periodization concept that's getting
more momentum
behind it in more studies and science
behind it - there's some interesting
folks that are looking into this in more
detail and if folks are really
interested in doing a deep dive in it
there's a guy named dr. mark Bub's he
wrote a book called peek and he kind of
dives into kind of like some of the
nutrition science where it's been and
kind of where it's it's kind of heading
and and they highlight some of that and
one of the big things they they're
starting to recognize that even with the
elite athletes when your period izing
your training like I do you know your
nutrition should be being periodized as
well you know the science is pretty
clear that like if you're doing a
workout and you take in glucose or
fructose I think most science says a two
to one ratio is ideal for maximizing the
moment you can take in then M you're
going to give yourself an advantage
that's like rocket fuel so then it
becomes a question of like do you need
that a hundred percent of the time or do
you even want to do it a hundred percent
of time because when we look at it
allows you right here when you say
glucose two-to-one like what do you mean
by that and within the coast of fructose
okay because what they found out is when
they started doing a lot of like the
exercise science and nutrition was that
the real limiter is your gut so like on
paper so absorption yeah uh-huh
yeah there's a finite amount you can
absorb and you increase the amount you
can you can absorb on average if you
have that two-to-one ratio versus all of
one or the other so - glucose - one
sucrose yeah mm-hmm interesting and now
what what are the different sources for
glucose versus sucrose like sucrose is
simple sugar you get is that more like a
refined sugar yeah yeah you I think like
the way like the most most like sports
supplements and things like that are
gonna be designed to kind of meet that
was those specific because they're
looking at the literature and they're
seeing like okay this is how you have
selected Powerade or Gatorade or
something like that would be a two to
one yeah I'd have to look to see exactly
if they have that but my guess would be
they would be if they're looking at at
the research and where that's kind of
that but yeah so like really wanna the
question that I think needs to be asked
with a lot of this stuff is like if I
want to make a workout feel as easy as
possible if I'm trying if I can get in
like say 60 grams of carbohydrate per
hour it's probably going to do that like
my pace my perceived effort at that pace
is probably gonna feel easier but then
you have to ask the question like how
often do you need it to feel that easy
so for me the answer to that is like
well if I'm doing something really
strenuous or something that's in a
little bit of a gray area where it's
just fast enough to dip into the
glycogen stores but just slow enough
that I can do it for quite a while and
make maybe even a couple hours then
you're kind of in this area where that
could be an advantage for you from
performance standpoint but if I'm going
out for an easy run of like 60 to 90
minutes and it's gonna be like a 2 to 3
out of 10 perceived effort anyway like
there's no real need for me to be
hitting glucose during that or you know
sports drink during that to make that
feel even easier yet because my goal
isn't necessarily to you know make an
easy run fill even easier I guess is the
way to later so you call a 90 minute run
easy nothing just a stroll just a few
dozen miles well and I think that that
also brings up a really good point too
where like a lot of this stuff when
we're looking at carbohydrate usage and
performances we're looking at elite
athletes we're looking at folks that are
training for like you know the Olympics
you know sometimes there are even
Olympic medalists and that's just not a
very good comparison I think to the
average person who's out there running
because you know they're learning their
purposes are different you know their
objectives are difference their lifes
are very different like one is doing
basically everything around a specific
specific date and distance and trying to
run as fast as they can on that date
another person may be trying to run as
fast as they can but there's so many
other factors in life like their work
their relationships their you know the
level of training they're actually able
to have with the time they have and then
also like you know managing their own
health and nutrition because like you
know elite athletes don't have a very
rosy picture in terms of long-term
health either so for someone who's like
you know maybe 10 20 pounds overweight
and is trying to run to get into shape
or train to get into shape or something
like that they're probably thinking just
as much about health as they are about
performance so for them to be you know
shuttling in 60 grams of carbohydrate
every hour during training and racing is
it's probably not the direction that
they'd want to go now when you get ready
to do something like this 100 mile run
how many miles do you run a typical day
and do ramp that
or do you just give yourself a base and
know that you can push through like how
do you handle that yeah so I'll build up
my training the way I kind of describe
it is like I'm always focusing on
specificity kind of being king so
depending on the race distance and the
intensity is kind of how I'm going to
structure my workouts so the rule of
thumb that I use is the closer I get to
the workout the more specific the
workouts I do are going to be towards
that race distance and intensity so for
me what that oftentimes means since I'm
training for like hundred mile distance
races is early in a training block I
might be doing some like shorter
interval work like vo2 max like an
example that would maybe be like a
three-minute kind of almost all out
effort followed by like a three-minute
recovery jog and then another
three-minute interval like that some of
those real short interval sessions and
how many those would you do in a row how
many Sprint's verses recovery yeah it'll
depend I'll start like pretty easy on
the first one I did the four when I
first started I might just do three by
three on that and what my goal really is
to every week is to kind of build volume
within that so that first week it might
be just three of them but by like say
the eighth week I might do a total of
like 24 to 27 minutes worth of volume
within that vo2 max context so it's it's
it really interesting because like you
know I could go out on any one day and
do like maybe ten of those but if I do
that and then it takes me like a week
and a half to recover from that session
it's not nearly as probably effective as
if I spread that out a little bit and
said did like five by three and then
five by three three days after that give
your body chance to recover and build
versus just destroying it all in one and
then feeling like [ __ ] for a couple
weeks exactly I like to I like to call
it micro stressing when I'm working with
folks and my own training I'm like we
want a micro stress we want to stress
you just enough to elicit a response and
as you get stronger and then we want to
do that over and over and over again are
you where you I'm sure you are you know
who Pavel Tatsu lenience yeah yeah so
he's got that sort of concept when it
comes to weightlifting with kettlebells
in particular calling greasing the
groove yeah whereas instead of doing all
these sets to failure you would just do
like half of what you're capable of and
then do it again in a more frequent pace
like do it again rather you know we'll
do it again on Wednesday do it again on
Friday and then give yourself a lot of
time in between each individual
activitytwo particularly in training for
strength he actually recommends as much
as ten minutes of recovery in between
sets which is you know kind of correct
me most people not all the time for that
you know six sets is an hour in I mean
it seems like you're just laying around
the gym people would if you were a gym
people in mock you but that's his
protocol mm-hmm yeah yeah and I think
it's I think it you know endurance is
like say it's a patient person's game so
I think if you can build that volume in
a you know micro stressing or in a like
a sustainable way that's what's gonna
keep you or get you strong and it's also
gonna make it less likely to get injured
how much time do you need like like if
you got you know up to that insane pace
that you did when you ran 100 miles when
if you took like a week off or two weeks
off how much would you lose not much in
that amount of time especially at that
intensity so the thing is is like the
648 mile pace you we need to be kind of
relative about it so like for me when
I'm out training when I'm not when I'm
not what I'm fully recovered that's like
a pretty reasonable pace from an
intensity standpoint so the interesting
thing about ultra marathon is race pace
is sometimes faster than even some of
your easiest runs and training so your
training is kind of all what we'd call
it over speed training hmm whereas in
most endurance events from like the 1500
up to like the marathon the majority of
your works gonna be sub
race pace and then you're gonna have
like depending on the program you know
maybe 20-30 percent of that be like over
speed training why is that well just
because the relative duration of the
event is so long like you know I can't
run fast or if I run too fast then it's
just gonna end badly for me right but
why is that with marathons oh well
because it's it becomes it's similar to
strength training where like if the
limiter is like the amount of like
stress you put on your body so if I was
gonna train to peak and say a marathon
my my max potential pace for that
wouldn't be sustainable to do every run
so I'd be running I'd be running too
hard too fast too often and then we'd
get into that that kind of a situation
that we're talking about before where
you're starting to macro stress versus
micro stress so if you run a marathon
what is your standard merit
on pace so I I'm a little goofy where I
competed in high school in college and
then I did some marathons but not really
in a structured manner and then I got an
ultra marathon running so I haven't
really done what I would consider a real
legitimate marathon training program so
you're basically saying marathons are
for [ __ ] right you're saying just say
I actually think the mayor
I do think marathons are maybe the
hardest event of them all I'll explain
why because you're going fast well yeah
it's just short enough where you have to
be pushing like a fairly intense pace
but it's just long enough where if you
make a mistake you're gonna pay for that
for quite some time so you're on such a
razor's edge and you're also just one
tiny mistake away from things going
really bad and what you're saying about
mistake you're talking about pacing okay
if you go out too hard yeah I see your
watch what is it what kind of watch
you're wearing
it's a Kouros apex what I've never heard
of that one before
had a GPS watch one of those yeah it's
it's relative they're a relatively new
brand like in in running I guess like
that to kind of big players historically
evincing toe and Garmin mm-hmm and
Quarles kind of came in the market a few
years ago they wanted to try to make
like take that high-end technology but
make it maybe a little more affordable
and also make it user friendly because
now everyone's there they care more
about the post-workout or the post run
data that you're uploading to these
platforms like Strava so like corals
kind of made it a big point to make it
really user friendly on that end so you
like I get done with the run and I
loaded up to the app and it's up on
Strava like within a few seconds
sometimes and then you go dissect all
the data like how much elevation gained
and lost your pace per mile is this
primarily a running watch I mean you
could use it for running or cycling or
hiking or mountaineering or anything
like that it's got like all those kind
of bells and whistles on okay so so if
you my question was like so if you're
running I want you are you're checking
your watch if you're doing a marathon
you're making sure that you're not going
crazy because it's is it otherwise you
just have to kind of gauge it just based
on the pack and based on how you feel
yeah and I think that's actually a good
especially when you get into ultra
marathon I think the metric that people
should dial in the most is the rate of
perceived exertion because that's
something that's not going to
necessarily
they lied to you like if you base your
thing your stuff off heart rate
exclusively or a pace exclusively you
can find yourself like justifying
something that's not necessarily where
you need to be and if something like
that malfunctions and that was your like
only compass then you're in trouble so I
like when I'm doing my training and when
I'm working with other folks I like to
use heart rate and I like to use pacing
and stuff like that but ultimately I'm
trying to get the person to really
understand like how hard is this effort
and then across the board from like very
easy to very difficult and then when it
comes time to race we can kind of dial
in like we this is the intensity you're
trying to look for so that they can kind
of feel that out do use a match or click
to you say like how do you feel 7 to 10
yeah pretty much
I I'll have a scale of like 1 to 10 that
I'll use a lot of times and there's like
a whole variety like most people are
gonna be using some sort of like
probably like zone system of training
where there's like there's numbers that
are associated with heart rate ranges or
intensities and there'll be descriptors
and you know there's some that are like
1 through 20 there's some that are kind
of 1 through 5 and then 1 through 10 and
is that so so weird too right because
it's so it's subjective I mean the
whoop-whoop strap is something I wear
and it uses something like that like
what's your perceived exertion of my own
I just push it towards the far right I
don't know like what does that mean like
it's it's all so hard to gauge your
perceived exertion especially when the
workouts over yeah I was hard I went on
went all out like what does that mean I
don't know what that means you know yeah
yeah it can be tricky and it is very
subjective but I think it's one of those
things where it falls into the same
category that a lot of endurance events
are where you just got to be patient and
really work on kind of understanding
that and you learn from experience too
like you you find out like oh I went and
did this workout and I thought that was
the right pace and intensity that turned
out to be a little too fast
dooty keep a training log yeah mm-hm and
do you like write it on Excel or
something like that yeah I basically
just load all my stuff up to Strava and
then yeah so that's kind of like the
go-to for most runners these days is I'm
sorry but do keep like a diary like
today felt like this and this was an
issue and I felt like I didn't have
enough fluids or do you do anything like
that not so much anymore I did it a lot
when I was in college and I did it a lot
when I first started when I was really
trying to kind of
learn my body and kind of learn what
things mean in in in how I respond to
them but now I've been kind of doing it
long enough where I have enough of a
like an understanding of kind of how
like when things go wrong like why they
did or if something went really well
like why it did that
I don't feel like I need to take as
detailed notes but I think it's really
valuable for someone who especially
while they're trying to learn rate of
perceived exertion and kind of really
dial those things in it's probably worth
a lot of worth a lot worth their time to
write that stuff down so that they can
look back at it and they have that
resource available to them as they're
kind of reflecting on things now say if
you're getting ready to do something
like this crazy 100 mile run trying to
break a world record what what do you
what how how much time you giving
yourself to really truly prepare for
that is it based on what how you're at
right now like what your baseline is
like what kind of preparation you've
done before you knew that this race was
available to you like how do you do that
mm-hmm ya know and this is this little
we can kind of hop back to where we're
talking about before because look when I
was talking about the vo2max work know
stuff that's kind of early in my
training plan because that intensity is
very unspecific to a hundred mile you
pace you know that's you know those vo2
max workouts are much closer to
something shorter like a 5k so what are
you trying to do with those of you - max
workouts you just trying to elevate your
your base yeah like just in like a here
look there's the different systems of
training and that's kind of a higher
intensity system so it's not very
relevant to the race pace that I'm doing
specifically but it's not irrelevant to
my overall like aerobic efficiency so
like by doing some of those faster stuff
things you can work on things like your
form and just because when you're
running that fast like things tend to be
a little more dialed in and it just it
expands it basically what you do is you
give yourself kind of a bigger range of
what your potential is gonna be when you
start focusing more and on like the
aerobic side of things that we're gonna
see like as I would move further down in
the training plan so once I kind of do
that section of training to answer your
question though like ideally I'll have
maybe about since I'm coming into most
programs not completely out of shape
like four months is kind of a sweet spot
for me
[Applause]